la sainte famille la situation est
délicate le sujet est sensible on parle
d'enfants maltraités des signalements
d'ailleurs été faits au procureur
les employés sont mises en cause pour la
déléguée du personnel les salariés sont
en souffrance elle pointe du doigt
l'organisation et l'administrateur
provisoire qui pour elle n'a pas joué
son rôle et sur les accusations de
maltraitances
elle tente des explications nous sommes
toujours dans un problème
organisationnel un problème de
management
et comment peut-on accuser des
professionnels de maltraitance si la
tête elle même ne va pas bien
le climat se dégrade plus lisse les
salariés sont démunis de moigné d'outils
de référentiels pour travailler et puis
effectivement les situations seront
maltraitance du côté de force ouvrière
le syndicat majoritaire pas question de
mettre en cause la mission de
l'administrateur provisoire qui selon
eux apporté des solutions pour sortir de
la crise aujourd'hui on aimerait que que
le grand public que la population qui a
tant entendu parler de nous ces jours ci
sachent que à la sainte famille il ya
des salariés compétents et les salariés
qui qui font tilt au travail les
salariés qui ont vu de cas de leur outil
de travail et qui sont dans une démarche
de formation formation qualité et nous
voulons faire taire cette minorité de
salariés qui je pense n'ont pas compris
les menaces
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas compris les
engins dans lesquelles nous nous
trouvons le 31 octobre prochain la
mission de l'administrateur provisoire
arrive à son terme
la city m devra alors décider du devenir
de la structure
il est évident que les
dysfonctionnements structurels qui
existe là cette famille depuis des
décennies note le met pas à cette
famille incapacité de poursuivre la
mission qui lui a été confié par le
conseil général et maintenant par la 7e
c'est la septième qui accorde des
autorisations donc nous étudions cette
piste la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
faudra voir aussi comment nous reprenons
ces enfants de ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
rupture et que les enfants ne subissent
pas les conséquences des décisions qui
vont être prises
mais n'oubliez pas que nous avons comme
unique souci
la protection des enfants c'est notre
mission sectionnelles demain un nouveau
volet judiciaire s'ouvre dans le dossier
de la sainte famille
le tribunal de grande instance devra
désigner un administrateur judiciaire